大家好,
我是Jim,
這裡是AI Notebook,
今天這一集,
我們繼續上史丹佛平行運算CS149,
這次是第七到第十二堂課,
老師是Kevin Fattahillian,
中間有三堂換成另一位教授Kuno Otokun,
這六堂課其實在回答同一個問題,
幾十萬件工作同時在跑,
碰到同一份資料的時候,
要怎麼辦?上一集的結論是,
難的不是算,
是搬,
這一集再往前走一步,
我先把答案放在前面。
難的不是分工是共用
把工作分出去
硬體人、程式庫都已經很會做了
真正麻煩的
是好幾個人手上拿著同一份東西
有人改了有人還在看舊的
上一集最後我們說
下一站是繪圖處理器
一顆晶片上幾萬個算數單元
要你準備好幾十萬件工作才為得寶
那我們就從這顆晶片開始
先問一個問題
它原本是拿來做什麼
KFone一開場就問了一個問題
NVIDIA和AMD做的這些晶片
當年主要是拿來玩一款叫Quick的射擊遊戲
怎麼會一路變成一家41兆美元的公司
比Intel大得多
全世界都在搶著買
這種晶片叫GPU
中文叫繪圖處理器
它原本只做一件事
給它一個虛擬的場景
算出攝影機會拍到什麼畫面
也就是替畫面上每一個小點算出顏色
一張CK的畫面
有幾百萬個點
一秒還要畫好幾十張
每個點的顏色各算各的
彼此不用等
所以做這種晶片的人
很早就一直往上加核心
加算術單元
KBON接著說
今天這堂課沒有新觀念
多核心SIMD多值形序
全是上一集講過的東西
只是規模放大了好幾百倍
這麼多核心
一開始只能拿來畫圖
大約20年前
史丹佛和北卡大學的研究人員發現
Intel的處理器不再變快
顯示卡卻每一代都在加核心
可是當時你沒辦法直接叫他跑程式
你只能丟給他一堆三角形
再附上一小段計算顏色的程式
於是他們在512x512的畫面上
畫兩個剛好蓋滿整個螢幕的三角形
這樣那段算顏色的程式
就會被執行26萬多次
接著他們偷偷換掉程式的內容
不算顏色啦
改成推進一部物理模擬
或者算蛋白質折疊
2004年
史丹佛有個研究計畫說
這樣太亂來了
既然它是平行處理器
就該有一套正經的寫法
三年後
NVIDIA自己出手
推出了正式的做法
2007年
NVIDIA推出了一套程式語言
叫CUDA
它的想法很簡單
你只寫一小段程式
然後告訴晶片
請把這段程式跑N份
每一份叫一條CUDA型序
每一條都知道自己的編號
再照編號去做屬於自己的那一份
例如你要把兩張12x6的表格相加
每一格派一條執行序
一共72條
那敘利亞還多了一層
執行序要先分組
每一組叫一個Thread Block
中文叫執行序區塊
你會發現
這跟上一集的ISPC幾乎一樣
Kvon說
ISPC當年就是
看到大家用CUDA寫顯示卡
才做出來的迴音
有一個細節要記住
你只決定要幾條執行序
怎麼分組
至於哪一組在哪個核心上跑
什麼時候跑
由晶片自己安排
那晶片拿到這些執行序
實際上怎麼跑
Kvon拿NVIDIA的E100來說明
案體會把編號連續的32條執行序綁成一組
這一組叫Warp
中文可以叫執行敘述
你可以把它想成操場上排成一列的32個人
大家聽同一個口令
口令喊舉手
32隻手一起舉起來
案體每一拍都會檢查
這32條是不是剛好走到城市的同一行
如果是就用一道指令一起做完
如果有人走到別的地方
就是上一集講的分歧
只好先讓一部分人做
其他人等著
在一般的處理器上
是編譯器替你把8個排成一組
在GPU上你寫的城市看起來每條各自獨立
自己把它們湊成一組
Cabin說這樣NVIDIA又會想把一組改成64個
你的程式也不用重寫
口令解決了一列32個人怎麼一起動
那一整個執行區區塊呢
Cabin用了一個很常見的例子
把一排數字模糊化
每個輸出的數字
這原本位置和左右兩個鄰居的平均
就像修圖軟體把照片變柔和
如果每條執行區自己去讀
鄰居之間讀的東西大半重疊
同一個數字會被搬好幾次
所以Kuda給每個區塊一小塊自己的記憶體
叫Shared Memory
中文叫共享記憶體
一個區塊有128條執行序
要算128個輸出
需要130個輸入
大家先分工
每人搬一個數字進來
搬完之後還有一行關鍵的程式
叫Sync Threads
意思是全員到齊才能往下走
要是拿掉這一行
跑得快的人會拿到還沒搬進來的數字
算出錯的答案
這是這集第一次碰到共用
大家要一起用同一份資料
就得先等所有人放好
那區塊跟區塊之間呢
這裡K1算了一個很驚人的數字
把V100上每個核心能掛的WAP全部乘起來
一顆晶片上同時有163,000條執行序代名
這些執行序不會同時再算
可是他們都在晶片上排好了隊
誰卡住在等資料
又換下一個上場
這就是上一集洗衣機那一招
放大到十幾萬倍
這麼多區塊
由誰來發
晶片最上面有一個排成器
看哪個核心還有空間
就把下一個區塊丟過去
所以CUDA定了一條規矩
同一個區塊的執行序
保證同時待在同一個核心上
你互相等
不同區塊之間
你不能假設誰先跑
如果你寫一個區塊
一四指跑得動一個
他就會永遠等下去
16萬條執行序擺在那裡
下一個問題就來了
你手上真的有這麼多事可以教給他嗎
Kevin下一堂課一開頭就說
想把一顆GPU用滿
你大概要準備20萬件以上的工作
這種方式叫資料平行
你不再去想開幾條執行序
而是把整堆資料當成一個整體
只對它做幾種固定的操作
他把這一整堆資料叫Sequence
中文叫序列
就是一排有順序的東西
你寫過NumPy或PTorch的話
其實天天都在這樣做
兩個大陣列中間放一個加號
你不會去想執行序
一般的陣列你可以隨時伸手拿第43格
序列不讓你這樣做
你只能透過他提供的操作去碰資料
很多先後關係
就是在你隨手拿別人那格的時候出現
不讓你亂拿就不會有人互相等
第一種操作最簡單
叫Map
中文叫Insert
你給他一個函式和一個序列
他把函式套在每一個元素上
產生一個一樣長的新序列
函式就是一臺小機器
放一個東西進去出來另一個東西
例如函式是加10
那整排數字就每個都加10
Kevin請大家站在寫Map的人那邊想
要讓他平行跑
你有把握嗎?
全班都說有
因為那個韓式只看得到自己手上那一個元素
他根本碰不到隔壁
想製造先後關係都做不到
你說清楚要做什麼
至於切成幾段開幾條執行序
那是寫Map的事
K文還說
我們在這門課寫過的程式
幾乎每一字都是Map
只是之前沒有叫他這個名字
這就跟前面那個口令一樣
每個人只管自己手上的東西
所以口令一喊
大家可以同時動
第二種操作叫Fold
中文可以叫折疊
他把一整排東西合成一個值
最常見的就是加總
那FOLD能不能平行
臺下有人馬上說
可以
第一堂課那16張紙不就是這樣
分幾段各自加
再把小記加起來
可是另一位同學舉手說
不一定
問題出在
你教給FOLD
函式不一定是加法
平行的做法會先各算各的
再把結果合起來
等到TOTAL改變了
先算哪兩個
加法沒關係
怎麼分組
答案都一樣
可是如果換成減法
10-3再減2
答案是5
10減掉3-2的差
答案卻變成9
K-1說
這個性質叫結合率
意思是先合
哪兩個都沒差
還是有結合率
Fold就能平行
沒有的話
你就只能乖乖從頭算到尾
有意思的是
它不需要交換率
前後順序不用換
只是分組可以變
第三種叫Scan
中文叫前最合
名字有點硬
但你天天都在用
你打開存摺
每一行都有一個餘額
那個餘額就是從第一筆
一路加到這一筆的總和
Scan做的就是這件事
它不只給你最後的總和
還給你每一步的小計
問題是
它看起來完全沒辦法平行
每一行都得等上一行算完
有同學說
先把前半段的總和算出來
後半段每一格加上它就好
他順著這個想法往下走
最後給出一個分兩趟的做法
頭一趟往上
兩箱家像一棵倒過來的樹
一層一層把小計往上合
第二趟往下
把合好的總和一路分回每一格
乘數很少
資料多一倍才多一層
總共做的加法
大約是從頭加到尾的兩倍
他說這個版本會是第三份作業的暖身體
你們要自己用酷打寫一次
故事到這裡有個轉折
真的放到GPU上
K本反而選了另一個看起來比較浪費的版本
浪費的版本很直接
每一步都讓每個人
跟前面某個人相加
32個數字
只要5步就做完
只是有很多加法是重複的
省工的版本加法比較少
卻要往上走5步
再往下走5步
一共10步
你猜哪個快
答案是浪費的那個
原因是32個人
聽的是同一個口令
你省下來的那些加法
並不會讓誰去做別的事
他們只是站在旁邊等
少做的工作換不到時間
所以他的結論是
要看你的機器長什麼樣子
只有兩個核心
就把資料切成兩半
各自從頭加到尾
最簡單的最快
有幾千個獨立的核心
就用省工的那棵樹
在同一個口令底下
就讓大家一起多做一點
最後Kevin出了一道題
你在做星系或流體的模擬
畫面上有幾百萬個粒子
空間切成四乘四
一共16個格子
你要做一張表
列出每個格子裡有哪些粒子
最直覺的寫法是
每個粒子算出自己在哪一格
然後拿一把鎖
把自己加進那一格的名單
臺下一起挑毛餅
10萬條GPU行去搶
用一把鎖
大家都在排隊
每一格一把鎖
也只有16把
先用一次Map
讓每個粒子算出自己的格子號碼
接著把所有粒子照格子號碼排序
同一格的自然排在一起
最後再用一次Map
每個人看自己跟左邊那個是不是同一格
不一樣的地方
就是一格的開頭
三步做完
沒有任何人碰同一份東西
看 問題從來不是分工
是那把大家都要搶的鎖
Keven那堂課最後提到一個叫Spark的系統
整個建立在同一個想法上
下一堂課
講臺換成另一位教授
Cornel O'Cotton
他把這個想法帶出一顆晶片
帶到一整座機房
為什麼要用一整群電腦
他舉了一個例子
像Facebook那樣的大網站
紀錄檔
動輒
幾百兆位元主
一臺電腦從硬碟一路讀下去
光是讀完就要23天
換成1000臺一起讀
就只要33分鐘
瓶頸不再算在硬碟送資料的速度
這個叫速度輸出頻寬
他還提到一位好朋友
Google的Louis Barroso
他把整座倉庫那麼大的機房
當成一臺電腦來設計
Barroso前不久過世了
1000臺電腦放在一起
麻煩也跟著來
Campio說
就算一臺伺服器平均25年才壞一次
你把1000臺擺在一起
差不多每個小時就有一臺出狀況
所以第一件事是資料不能丟
做法叫分散式檔案系統
Google最早做的叫GFS
後來有開放原始碼的版本叫HDFS
他把一個巨大的檔案切成一塊一塊
每一塊都複製好幾份
放在不同的機櫃裡
機櫃就是一整排疊起來的伺服器
頂上的網路設備一壞
整排都會斷線
這一集接下來會一直用到一個畫面
影印本
正本只有一份
為了保險
你印了三份放在三個不同的抽屜
這個抽屜打不開
你還有別的可以拿
另外有一臺總管的機器
記著每一份影印本放在哪裡
要讀資料的人先問他
再直接去抽屜拿
資料保住了
接下來要算
Conto出了一道很生活的題目
假設CS149
紅到大家都想來修
課程網站的瀏覽紀錄
多到要放在好幾臺機器上
你想知道同學都用什麼手機在看
他用的方法叫MapReduce
你只要寫兩個小函式
一個叫Mapper
每一行紀錄交給他
他看看是不是手機
是的話就記一筆
例如Safari加1
另一個叫Reducer
同一個鍵的所有數字交給他
他負責加總
鍵就是分類的標籤
中間還有一步你看不到
但很貴
系統要把所有機器上Safari的那幾筆
全部送到同一臺機器上
這一步叫Shuffle
意思是洗牌
重新分堆
Map要放在哪臺機器跑
早年網路很慢
所以資料在哪裡就在哪裡跑
程式搬過去
比資料搬過來便宜
又回到上一集那句話
真正貴的是搬
Redri就是撐得住一千臺機器
靠的是一個很小的性質
Count1全搬
Map還有什麼重要的地方
有同學答出來
他不改自己的輸入
原本那一份紀錄
還是原封不動
這也讓壞掉變得不可怕
每臺機器會定時送一個訊號給總管
意思是我還活著
這個叫心跳
心跳一停
總管就知道他掛了
把他手上的工作
交給另一臺
有同一份影印本的機器重做一次
因為輸入沒被改過
重做幾次答案都一樣
還有一種麻煩
機房裡的機器新舊不易
舊得特別慢大家都在等他
解法很直接
同一份工作再派給另一臺
兩臺一起跑
誰先做完就用誰的
另一臺直接停掉
你可能會覺得浪費
可是比起一千臺一起等一臺
這點浪費很便宜
說穿了
只要大家不去改共用的那一份
出事就能重來
MapReduce有一個大缺點
每做完一輪Map和Reduce
結果都要寫回分散式檔案系統
下一輪再讀出來
如果你的演算法要一直重複
例如Google最早拿來替網易排名的PageRank
要跑很多輪
每一輪都在硬碟和記憶體之間來回搬
那資料放得進記憶體嗎
他給大家看一篇2011年的論文
標題很直接
資料中心裡的硬碟區域性已經不重要了
裡面有一張表用的是2009年Facebook的資料
一臺機器只要64GB的記憶體
就放得下97%的常用資料
所以問題不是放不下
是MapReduce這套寫法
逼你每一輪都把東西送回硬碟
放在記憶體當然快
可是記憶體一斷電就沒了
這就是下一個系統要解決的事
Spark就是為這件事做的
它的核心叫RDD
中文叫彈性分散式資料集
你只要記得它的三個特點
有順序
只能讀不能改
而且只能從別的RDD或硬碟上的檔案編出來
先從檔案讀出每一行
就是第一個RDD
挑出手機的那幾行
變成第二個
再挑出Safari的
變成缸
第三個
最後數一數又幾筆
每一步都產生新的一份
舊的那份從來沒被改過
這一連串步驟叫Lineage
中文叫血統
意思是這份資料是怎麼一路變出來的
我覺得更像一張食譜
你不必把每一道半成品都冰進冰箱
也就是寫回硬碟
只要把它們放在爐臺上
也就是記憶體
再把食譜記好
萬一哪一鍋打翻了
照食譜從頭再做一次就好
能這樣做是因為原料沒有被動過
同一份食譜
做幾次都是同一道菜
Spark讓一整座機房變成一臺電腦
下一堂K版回來
把鏡頭拉回一顆GPU
看他現在最常被拿去做的事
跑神經網路
他先把神經網路講得很樸素
一個神經元
說穿了就是拿一排輸入
跟一排權重做點積
也就是對應的數字相乘再加起來
最後跟零比一比
取比較大的那個
權重就是一排跳好的數字
很多神經元疊成一層一層
就是深度神經網路
引向你最常見的一種運算
叫卷積
它用修圖來說明
每個輸出的點
是原本那個點
跟周圍八個點的
平均九個數字
各成九分之一
整張圖就變模糊了
可是隻要把這九個權重換掉
有正有負
同一段程式就不再是模糊
而是在找邊緣
找橫的線或直的線
神經網路做的
是讓電腦自己學出這些權重
在談怎麼算快之前
可以往前提醒一件
很多做系統的人會忽略的是
要讓神經網絡變快
有三條路
頭一條跟這門課無關
是設計更好的網絡
他拿幾年間
陸續出來的影像網絡來比
準確度差不多
可是需要的權重和計算量
在大約四年裡少了25倍
硬體不可能在四年裡快25倍
Google為了讓網絡塞進手機
有人花了兩年
一直調濾金要幾個
要疊幾層
最後做出一個叫
MobileNet的網絡
他說
現在的大型語言模型也一樣
先做出一個夠好的工程師
接著就會想辦法把它縮小
所以如果你只盯著
今天最紅的那個模型
拼命最佳化
一年後可能整個方向都錯了
做系統的人
也得跟著演算法走
第二條路
才是這門課的主場
網路定下來了
要讓他在手上的晶片跑快
K-Bone調了一招很常見的做法
把卷積變成矩陣乘法
矩陣就是一張排好的數字表格
矩陣乘法就是兩張表格
交叉相乘再相加
為什麼要變
因為世界上已經有人把
矩陣乘法做到極致
你邪不贏他們
做法是這樣
每個輸出的點需要周圍9個輸入
那就把這9個數字超成一橫排
每個輸出點一排
排成一張大表
再跟權重相乘
問題也跟著出現
同一個輸入點會被超近好幾排
整張表比原本的圖大了9倍
記憶體一下就被塞滿
所以比較新的做法叫影視矩陣乘法
程式照著矩陣乘法的樣子跑
卻從來不把那張大表真的超出來
要用到哪一格
就當場算出它在原圖的哪個位置
直接去拿
那矩陣乘法本身要怎麼寫才快
最簡單的寫法是三層迴圈每算一個答案
就讀一整稜牌和一整支牌
Kevin問大家這樣有什麼問題
答案是你讀了兩個數字才做一次乘加
這跟上一集那個只用到1%算力的加法是同一種情況
全都卡在半
可是矩陣乘法照理不該這樣
它要做的乘法比資料多很多
每個數字照理可以被用上很多次
解法叫分塊英文叫blocking
把大矩陣切成一塊一塊小方塊
大小剛好放得儘快去
一次拿兩塊進來
把這兩塊之間所有該做的乘法全部做完
再換下一塊
上一集那張書桌又回來了
你一次把兩疊搬上桌
全部用源再搬下一疊
他說你在C語言裡花15分鐘寫這兩個版本
矩陣夠大的話速度可以差到1000倍左右
一層算快啦
還有一個更大的浪費
藏在層與層之間
每一層算圓
就把一大張結果寫回
顯示卡的主記憶體
下一步再整張讀回來
處理完再寫回去
這些小步驟幾乎沒有運算
全帶搬
解法叫融合
把連續幾步併成一步
結果還在晶片上就接著做完
K-Ball說有一個很漂亮的例子
他就在一年半前在史丹佛發明
讓大型語言模型的注意力層快了很多
注意力層要把每個字
跟其他每個字配對打分數
一萬個字
就是一億格的表
每一橫排還要做一件事
叫softmax
他得先知道整排最大的那個數字
才能換算
可是有人發現
只要一邊算
一邊記著目前為止最大的數字和總和
就能一塊一塊做完
那張巨大的表
從頭到尾都不用存下來
能處理的長度
從八千個字
一路拉到三萬兩千個字
凱凡說
他相信GPT-4背後就有這種最佳化
最後Kvon問
GPU為什麼這麼適合跑神經網絡
全班答得很快
平行度多
算術單元多
那他哪裡還不夠好
他把話題帶回上一集的SIMD
SIMD的道理是
讀一次指令
看懂一次指令
這些雜事的成本
貪給很多次運算
那何不走得更遠
NVIDIA自己估計
如果只用一般的加法和乘法指令
去做矩陣乘法
能源效率比專門為他做的晶片
差2000倍
改成一道指令
就做完一個4x4的小矩陣乘法
差距就一下子縮到很小
NVIDIA的回應
是在GPU裡加了Tensor Core
中文叫張亮核心
名字聽起來很厲害
其實它就是一道專門做小矩陣乘法的大指令
你還記得那個口令嗎
以前一個口令是一個動作
現在一個口令就是一整套動作
只要你的運算寫得成矩陣乘法
尖峰算力一下子多了10倍以上
下一堂課空流回到講臺
先把SPARK收尾
你還記得那張食譜嗎
它示範了一個機器當掉的情況
一串步驟正做到一半
一號機器突然掛了
他記憶體裡那兩塊資料全部消失
控控說
總管手上有那張食譜
也就是Lineage
他知道這兩塊是從硬碟上
拿幾份檔案
經過哪幾道步驟變出來的
原始檔案
在分散式檔案系統裡
有好幾份影印本
不會丟
所以照著食譜重做那兩塊就好
別的機器完全不受影響
食譜還有另一個好處
Spark看得懂每一步在做什麼
如果每一塊依賴前一步的同一塊
這叫載相依
他就能把幾步併成一步
中間結果根本不用存
這跟剛才GPU上的融合是同一招
反過來
像一鍵分組這種
要從每臺機器收資料的步驟
叫寬箱一
就沒辦法秉持
嫩撈老實實的辦
Spark比起老的Hadoop
重複運算的每一輪
快了一個數量級以上
只空口接著潑了一盆冷水
現在一臺大伺服器
就能裝到一兩TB的記憶體
很多研究拿Spark做實驗
資料其實只有幾GB
一臺機器就放得下
有一張表
比較了Twitter的社群關係圖
好20輪PageRank
Spark用了128個核心
還比一臺電腦上的一條直行虛慢了兩倍
一位叫Frank McSherry的研究者講得很直接
他說大數據系統的研究
把可擴展性捧得比什麼都高
可擴展性就是機器加的越多跑得越快
意思是先造出一堆開銷
再想辦法省回來
Conco的結論很樸素
資料真的有幾百TB
你只能用分散式系統
資料不到1TB
一臺機器通常快得多
這跟上一集那句話是同一件事
不要為了平行而平行
接著Colo回到一顆晶片
進入這一集最核心的問題
學生用的那臺機器
每個核心有自己的小快取
四個核心
再共用一個比較大的快取
快取裡的每一格
除了資料
還貼著幾張標籤
一張叫tag
記著這一格
其實是記憶體的哪一段
另一張叫dirty bit
中文叫張衛元
意思是這一格被改過了
跟記憶體裡的不一樣
為什麼會不一樣
因為現在的快取
大多是寫回式的
你寫資料
只寫在快取裡
不急著送回記憶體
等這一格要被別人擠掉的時候
才寫回去
我們用影音本來看
記憶體是正本
快取是你手上的影音本
你直接在影音本上改字
改原在角落貼一張紅色便利貼
提醒自己正本還是舊的
一臺機器
只有一個人的時候沒問題
換成四個核心
四個人手上都有同一頁的影音本
事情就來
康頭在臺上一步一步演給大家看
有一個變數X
一開始在記憶體裡是0
1號處理器讀它
影音一分到自己的快取
拿到的是0
2號也讀
也拿到0
1號把它改成1
改在自己的影音本上
3號去讀
記憶體還是0
所以他拿到0
接著他改成2
2號
這時候再讀
他自己手上那份還在
直接拿來用
讀到的是0
最後1號處理器的快取要騰出為止
把他手上那份寫回記憶體
記憶體變成1
你現在看看整個系統
記憶體說X是1
3號說是2
2號說是0
1號手上已經沒有了
同一個變數出現三個答案
有同學問
加鎖不就好了
他說不行
鎖只能讓大家輪流改
可是就算輪流
每個人還是改在自己的營運本上
別人手上那份照樣是舊的
問題不再強
在同一份資料
同時存在系統裡
好幾個地方
這種毛病叫快取不一致
那一致應該長什麼樣子
康口先講直覺
任何一個位置
你讀它
就該拿到
最後一次寫進去的值
可是最後一次是什麼意思
兩個人同時寫
誰算最後
所以他把他說得更精確
對
同一個位置
所有人的讀跟寫
要能排成一條隊
而讀到的
永遠是隊伍裡
前個寫進去的值
要做到這件事
Anti守著兩條規則
一條叫單一寫者
要嘛 只有一個人可以改
那要嘛 大家都只能讀
另一條叫資料值不變
意思是一段只能讀的時間裡
每個人讀到的
都是前一段那個唯一寫者
最後留下的字
用影印本來說
這一頁同時只能有一支筆
筆在誰手上
別人的影印本就得作廢
等筆放下大家再重新影印
有同學問
那不寫快取不就沒事了
沒錯
可是每次都跑記憶體
速度就沒了
一支筆的規則
要靠什麼來執行
一種做法是乾脆
不要各自的快取
大家共用一個
Control說他以前設計過一顆叫Nagra 2的處理器
第二層快取就是8個核心共用
可是每個核心都要拉線連到快取
到了8個核心
差不多就是極限
另一種做法叫窺探
每個核心的快取都接在同一條匯流排上
匯流排就是一組大家共用的線
Control說匯流排有兩個好性質
就像這間教室裡的空氣
一個人開口
所有人都聽得到
這叫廣播
同一時間只能有一個人講話
這叫排序
所以每個快取都一直豎著耳朵
聽匯流排上有沒有人說
我要改某一頁了
聽到了
而且自己手上剛好有那一頁
就把自己的影音本作廢
最簡單的版本
是沒寫一次就廣播一次
可是這樣匯流牌馬上塞爆
所以真正的做法
要搭配剛才的寫回式快取
下一堂課
空調把真正的規則寫出來
這套規則叫MSI協定
三個字母是三種狀態
M是Modify
以修改
這一頁只有你有
而且你改過了
你就是那個拿著筆的人
S是Shared
共享
好幾個人都有
大家都只能讀
這時候記憶體裡的正本
一定是最新的
I是invalid
無效
就是你手上沒有
或者被作廢了
1號想讀在匯流牌上
喊一聲
我要讀
他拿到一份
狀態是共享
3號也讀
也是共享
3號想改在匯流牌上喊
我要讀
而且要改
1號聽到了
把自己那份作廢
3號變成已修改
接著1號又想讀
喊了一聲
這次是3號跳出來
把他改好的那份交出去
兩個人一起回到共享
你會發現
1號本來讀自己手上那份就好
現在因為3號寫過
他得多走一趟匯流牌
就這樣變成延遲的
MSI有一個小浪費
先讀再寫是很常見的動作
可是這樣要喊兩次
一次說我要讀
一次說我要改
所以多了一個狀態
叫e-exclusive讀佔
意思是這一頁只有你有
但你還沒改
康克爾說這個協定叫MESI
跟那位阿根廷足球巨星同名
有了讀佔
你讀的時候如果發現沒人有這一頁
就直接拿讀佔
你要改的時候不用再喊
悄悄的就能改
另一個問題出在匯流牌本身
每一次喊話
所有核心都得聽
連手上根本沒有那一頁的也要停
核心一多就撐不住了
所以現在大部分處理器改用目錄
最大那層共用快取的每一格旁邊
都附了幾個位元
記著四個核心裡
誰手上有這一頁
要作廢的時候
只去通知手上真的有的那幾個
不用對全體廣播
靠著目錄
核心可以做到幾十個甚至上百個
你聽到這裡可能會覺得
這些都是硬體的事
跟寫程式的人沒關係
康求用一組數字告訴你
差很多
在Intel的Core i7上
你要的東西在最大那層快取裡
而且只有你在用
大約40個10M週期就拿到
10M週期就是處理器打一拍的時間
如果那一格好幾個核心都有
要65個週期
如果它剛被另一個核心改過要75個
差不多是兩倍
他說
一支程式從一個人跑變成很多人跑
平均每次拿資料的時間一定會變長
因為公用會把你的存取
推到更慢的那幾層去
這就是公用的價錢
它不會讓你的程式出錯
硬體已經替你把張對好了
可是它會安靜的讓你變慢
Conto建議用Intel的VTune這類工具
但是哪個資料結構一直錯過快取
更麻煩的是
有時候你根本沒有共用
硬體卻以為你有
剛剛就舉了一個例子
四條直行序
每條有一個自己的計數器
各加各的
完全不相干
一種寫法是把四個計數器
放在一個陣列裡緊緊挨著
另一種寫法
讓每個計數器各自佔滿一整排快取行
在一臺四核心的機器上
前一種跑了14.2秒
後一種只要4.7秒
程式邏輯卻一模一樣
原因是快取一次辦一整排
上一集講過
這一排叫快取行
四個計數器擠在同一排裡
就像四個人各自在同一頁影音本上改不同的字
可是作廢是整頁作廢的
一號改了他那一格
其他三個人整頁作廢
重新影音
一號一改
又整頁作廢
那頁就在四個人之間來回飛
這個現象叫偽共享
英文叫false sharing
解法很簡單
把資料隔開
雖然浪費一點空間
意志性只管同一個位置
不同位置之間誰先誰後
是另一個問題
叫記憶體意志性模型
Countio寫了四行程式
請大家跟旁邊的人討論
A跟B一開始都是0
1號處理器先把A設成1
再印出B
2號處理器先把B設成1
再印出A
請問可能印出哪些結果
臺下有人說01
有人說11
大家幾乎都同意
00不可能
為什麼
要印出00
1號印B的時候
2號還沒設B
2號印A的時候
1號也還沒設A
可是每個人都是先設再印
你把這些先後關係畫成箭頭
會繞成一個圈
一件事的發生在自己之前
這不可能
這種直覺有一個正式的名字
叫循序一致性
是Leslie Lampert定義的
他後來拿了土林獎
意思是所有人的動作
可以排成一條隊
而每個人自己的動作
都造成是的順序
可是真實的處理器
印得出00
寫入常常要等很久
後面那個讀取
卻可能馬上就在快取裡拿到
何必讓讀取乾等
所以處理器
加了一個寫入緩衝區
你可以想成桌角的帶送欄
寫好的東西先放進欄子
晚一點再送出去
讀取先走
這樣1號把A設成1
還躺在自己的欄子裡
他就去讀B
拿到0
2號同時也一樣
也拿到0
00就這樣出現了
Conco還提醒
你口袋裡那隻手機
用的是更寬鬆的規則
幾乎什麼順序都能換
那要順序怎麼辦
加一道柵欄
英文叫Fence
他讓所有人把手上的毒血都送完
才準往下走
他說平行運算底要解決問題
常常就是讓東西慢下來
他給的建議很實在
共用的資料一定要用同步保護好
不要讓兩個人在沒有約定的情況下
碰同一個位置
剩下的交給寫同步程式庫
和編譯器的人去傷腦筋
我們回到開場那個問題
這一集你看到GPU把16萬條執行序排在一顆晶片上
分工全交給硬體
只讓同一個區塊裡的人共用
你看到Cable不用鎖
改用排序
看到Spark靠著從不修改的資料
還一張食譜
撐過一千臺機器隨時會壞
最後你看到
四個核心手上的影印本
光是要讓同一頁保持一樣
就得作廢
重印
喊話
還會在你根本沒共用的時候
把你拖慢好幾倍
所以難的不是分工
是共用
下一集是正門課的最後幾堂
我們會看到大家搶同一份資料時
不用鎖要怎麼辦
專門為一種問題設計的程式語言
一種叫交易式記憶體的想法
為了特定工作打造的硬體
最後再回到記憶體存取
把整門課收起來
最後問你一個問題
如果你跟同事要同時改同一份文件
你們會先講
好 誰能改
還是各改各的
最後再來對版本
留言跟我分享
喜歡這種把公開課講清楚的內容
也可以訂閱AI Notebook
我是Jim 我們下次見